- Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the Homeroom live stream,
Sal here from Khan Academy.
I'm excited about our conversation today
with Dan Roth, Editor
in Chief of LinkedIn.
A lot to talk about on
both the future of work
and a lot on just the future of media too,
I think, it will be a really
interesting conversation.
So start thinking of your questions
and putting them in the message boards
wherever you happen to be seeing this.
And we're gonna surface
as many of the questions
as possible to Dan.
But before we do that,
I will make my standard announcements.
First of all, a reminder
that we are not-for-profit.
We can only exist with your
philanthropic donations.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to KhanAcademy.org/donate.
Also I want to make a special shout out
to several organizations that stepped up,
during COVID especially,
many of them were supporting
us even before COVID.
But when we saw that
our costs had gone up,
a lot more folks were dependent
on Khan Academy and continued to be,
a special thanks to Bank of America,
Google.org, AT&T, Fastly, and Novartis,
and the many other funders and
supporters of Khan Academy,
pre and during COVID, and
hopefully post-COVID as well.
We need your help,
we continue to need your help,
we have a gap for 2021.
Also quick reminder,
you can get a version of this live stream,
"Homeroom with Sal, the podcast,"
wherever you get your podcasts.
So with that, I'm excited
to introduce Dan Roth.
Dan, good to see you.
- Great to see you,
thanks for having me on.
- So maybe the first thing,
just to get everyone acquainted,
I think most people know about LinkedIn.
And I think most folks, you
know, at the high level,
it's kind of the social
network for business.
They view it as a place
where you can look for jobs,
find jobs, find interesting things
that are going on in the business world.
Why does LinkedIn have a Editor in Chief?
What is it you do?
- Yeah, it's a great question.
It's a great question, and I
ask myself that all the time.
So I have been at LinkedIn
for almost 10 years now,
nine and a half years.
I joined LinkedIn when LinkedIn was moving
from being a place to connect
professionals with each other,
to being a place that
serves as a way for people
to connect to economic opportunity.
And at the time before joining LinkedIn,
I was a long time writer and editor
at "Fortune," "Wired," "Forbes."
I'd help start a magazine
called Conde Nast Portfolio,
which was a business magazine
started by Conde Nast,
and had always been a business journalist
just trying to explain to the
world and to professionals
how business worked.
At the time, LinkedIn Jeff Weiner,
who was the CEO of LinkedIn,
was thinking about the
next evolution of LinkedIn.
And his thinking was that if we are going
to serve the mission of LinkedIn,
which is not just to connect people
but to help make them
better at what they do
or what they want to do,
we do that by helping them stay informed
and helping make sure that
they are building their own voice.
And the way that you do
that is through getting them
the right news at the right time,
and then getting them to talk about it.
And so to do that well,
you need an editor.
So he hired me and I built up a team.
We have about 75 editors around the world
who curate content, cultivate new voices,
or trying to find people
who are uniquely qualified
to talk about certain things
and bring them on LinkedIn.
And then we curate the
best of what we see.
So curate, cultivate, create.
These are mostly business
journalists like myself,
and we are just trying to make sure that
we are serving up high
quality information to people
so that when you come to LinkedIn,
your time is spent,
that is a valuable use of your time.
That if you are no matter,
what you do for a living,
when you come to LinkedIn,
you should find some news
that's interesting to you that helps you
get smarter at what you're doing
or helps you make a connection
or connect dots from around the world.
And to do that well, you
need editors and algorithms.
So we work really closely
with our relevance engineers,
we make sure that we are giving people
what they want in their world,
but also helping them
helping pop filter bubbles,
and make sure they are seeing
what is going on in the world around them.
That's what I do.
- It's fascinating because
it's a very different take
than some of the other
social media platforms,
obviously that aren't
quite as business focused.
But if you take a Twitter,
if you take a Facebook,
you know, the news is in
theory all user-generated,
and they have increasingly
fallen under scrutiny of,
hey, what if someone
posts something that is,
you know, inciting violence
or it's just inaccurate.
And so they they're having
to do a little bit more
policing function but they're definitely
not creating their own content.
Why do you think LinkedIn
has gone down this path,
and what do you think has been
the pros and cons of doing that?
- Sure.
It is important to us that
when people come to LinkedIn,
they know that this is a place
where they can trust what
they see in LinkedIn.
If you look, the Business
Insider does a survey every year
of social, of trust in social media,
LinkedIn for, I don't
know, four years running,
three, four years running,
is the number one most
trusted social media site.
The way that we do that and
the way that we maintain it
is by one, making sure
we have real identities.
When you come to LinkedIn,
you are coming with your
professional identity,
you are saying who you work for,
who you have worked for in the past.
And then we are connecting you
with your colleagues who can vouch for you
or talk about what you're good at also.
When you come to your feed,
you should have a feeling that,
just like you're seeing real people,
that you are seeing real news
and information on there.
So we have always believed
that it is important
to have an editorial voice
and an editorial perspective on LinkedIn.
So for instance, with the latest election,
if you open your app right now
and you go to your notifications tab,
you'll see something at the top that says,
"The 2020 election," "The
latest on the 2020 election."
If you click there,
if you're in the US I should say,
if you click there,
you'll end up on a page
that is created and curated by editors
that says here is exactly
what is going on with the election.
This is trusted information
from trusted sources.
And we'd ran this all the way
through the election process.
And it's still up there today.
It is important that if you
are, no matter what you do,
if you come to LinkedIn,
that you have that one place
to go to get that information
and say, here is what's
going on in the world.
I can trust what I'm seeing here.
You asked about UGC,
user-generated content is the
heart and soul of LinkedIn.
What we create as editors
is a drop in the bucket
versus what our members
create every single day
through their articles
and their posts, videos,
images that they're
putting up on LinkedIn.
They are talking to their world about
what's going on around them
and what they're seeing.
And we as editors are trying to get
more and more of that content from them.
So we'll reach out every day to people
who might be in the news,
whether they know it or not.
So let's say for instance that
there's a big merger going on.
We could reach out to people
who are in that industry
saying, can you explain what,
you know, Spotify is buying Megaphone,
can you talk about what this means
for the future of podcasting?
And people who are in
the podcasting business
would get this alert
and they might say like,
oh yeah, I have something
that I am qualified
to talk about, that I want to share.
There's something that's
in the back of my head
that I've talked to my colleagues about,
but if I can share it with
the world, maybe something,
maybe an even better conversation happens.
And so we get them to
share that on LinkedIn.
And then, I think the last point is that
you asked about like
how this is different.
The big difference is that
we're a professional social media site.
What you write here is seen by your boss
and your colleagues and
your future colleagues
and people who you might
want to work for you one day
when you start your own business.
All of that increases the, I think-
Oh for a lot of us, sharing
on social is always worrisome.
But when you come to LinkedIn,
you know, there's that extra concern.
What is my boss gonna say when
they see what I've written?
What are my employees gonna say?
And so we as editors can
help guide people to say
this is a topic that is
worth weighing in on.
People are hungry to hear from you
on this thing that's going on in the news.
And this is a safe thing to talk about.
So I think unlike some other social media
where you might fire it up and talk about
whatever you feel like talking about,
there's an extra level of
concern and seriousness
that takes place on LinkedIn
because of the professional profile.
- I'm curious, and I
definitely want to talk about
the future of work which
I know is another area
that you have a lot of expertise,
but, you know, this whole
notion of social media
and misinformation, it's such a hot topic.
And it does seem like LinkedIn
has threaded the needle quite well
of having a lot of user-generated content,
also having some
editorially curated content,
and also just by the nature of it
being real identities, et
cetera, everything you mentioned.
It seems like you're doing a good job.
What do you think is the future
of some of the other
social media platforms?
I mean, I actually, you know,
I've thought a lot about this issue.
I don't have a simple
solution for, you know,
how do you balance people being
able to put ideas out there
while some ideas are from Russian bots,
or just people who are trying
to put out misinformation?
Where do you think this is gonna go?
- You know, I wish I knew.
I can tell you that my own beliefs
about what's important
for us to figure out
in the social media landscape
is how do we make sure
that there are real
identities behind everything.
That I think that there is-
One of the key drivers
to LinkedIn's success
has been this idea that
you have to stand for what you are saying.
There are some people that
don't mind saying crazy things
in knowing that it's
under a real identity,
that is always gonna happen,
but it definitely raises the bar.
It should make you think twice
about what it is that you're saying.
So I think that's really important.
And I think that what the other
social media sites are doing
in terms of labeling
content is really important.
I think the role of fact
checkers is important.
I hope that social media sites
keep investing in those areas.
And then I guess the
last thing I would say
is that I think that-
I watch how my kids use social,
and it's very different
than the way I think older
generations use social.
They go into it with a
certain understanding
of what it's for and what it's not for,
and when to take it seriously
and when not to take it seriously.
And also I think when to hop off.
And I wonder if this generation
that has grown up with social
as being the primary way that they are,
not just getting information
but building their voice,
has a better handle on
what they're seeing there.
That, because they are also the ones
putting up jokey content,
that they can recognize
when someone is trolling.
Because maybe they're
trolling themselves also.
And so I do think there will be a change
in how damaging social can be.
Or the downsides, when people
have much more information
or they're intrinsically
get what the weaknesses are
with what they might be
seeing on certain sites
where there is no anonymity,
where anyone can post anything
and where people are saying stuff
just to get a rise out of you.
- Yeah, yeah, and I hope you're right.
I mean, we've had guests
on before talking about,
that this generation that's
growing up on social media,
all of the negatives that it might have,
but they might also be
building some skillsets.
So, you know, pivoting a little bit,
we're obviously in the
midst of a COVID crisis,
it looks like you're working from home,
I'm working from home.
What's your view, you know,
what are you seeing in LinkedIn?
What are you doing in reporting?
What's your view that you're
having of the future of work,
and COVID especially,
how it might impact that?
- I think that it's a big question.
And I think there are a lot of
different ways to look at it.
There are certain industries
that we have seen through our data
that are just getting absolutely,
that are in such serious pain,
that I think it's hard to
think about how they come back.
And there are others that
are doing extremely well.
- What are the ones that you think
might have trouble coming back?
- Well, I think leisure and hospitality,
it's gonna be a long time
before they come back.
And there could be a point where
coming back is no longer an option
because you have lost years of knowledge.
You've had to cut to the bone.
You have lost people's-
How people spend their money
and what they do in their
leisure time has changed.
So I think it's gonna be years
before business travel comes back.
And because I think we're all learning
how to do these kinds of calls from home.
There was a, I think it
was the CEO of Infosys,
massive Indian outsourcing IT firm,
that said look, I used to
get on a plane and fly,
and I would fly to the
US for a $5 million deal.
Now we're closing $2
billion deals over VC,
over these kind of calls.
One, you realize you have to do that,
you don't have to go pack a bag,
you don't have to get trapped
in an airplane for eight hours,
you don't have to deal with jet lag,
going back to that's really difficult.
I do an interview series also on LinkedIn,
I was talking to David Chang,
the founder of Momofuku yesterday,
and he's a big giant restaurateur,
and he says, look,
without business travel,
restaurants don't come back.
We've relied on that lunch traffic
and that breakfast traffic
to be able to pay for so much else
of what goes on in the restaurant,
in the restaurant world.
It's not just leisure dinners.
And so you start seeing
these downstream impacts
where a lot of leisure
and travel don't come back
if business travel doesn't come back.
Cruises, when do cruises come back?
I think that's gonna be a long time.
So anything that involves us
getting together in person,
I think, will take a while to come back
and will come back in a different form.
What we've seen on LinkedIn is the people
who are in those industries
are very actively
trying to get out of those industries.
They've realized that there
is a need to find a path
that takes you from this
area into something else.
And I think that's accelerating-
You know, I don't know if
you've had Professor Galloway,
Scott Galloway, on your show before,
but he has this theory
that what COVID is doing
is just accelerating trends
that were already in the works.
So virtual big tech getting bigger,
and I would add to that this
kind of skills-based workforce,
this idea that what you do is
really a collection of skills
versus you being an expert
in one particular job.
So, as an example of that, like,
you could be a great travel-
You might be a great, I
don't know, person in travel.
You might be a good travel,
anything in travel, and you
have to just think about
what the atomized set of skills
are that make up your job,
and then where else you
could apply those skills.
I think my favorite example of this is,
I was talking to someone
at a insurance company
who said that when they look
for insurance adjusters,
people that can work with
people around their accidents,
and try to understand what
happened and who's at fault
and whatever else goes into
being an insurance adjuster,
this executive said, we hire bartenders.
Because bartenders have this ability
to get people to tell their stories.
And I think if you're a bartender,
you don't think of yourself
as being a story aggregator.
But that's a skill.
It's a skill to get people to talk.
And once you start thinking of your work
in terms of what are the skills
that go into what do I do,
versus I identify myself as a bartender,
the world starts opening up to you.
And I think that is accelerated by COVID,
is people realizing that
they've built their careers
on potentially shaky ground,
and that if they are
going to continue to work
it is gonna come from being able to hop
from industry to industry and job to job.
And it's your skills that
will enable you to do that.
- And what do you think about
the in-person workplace?
What do you think about, you know,
out here in Silicon
Valley some people say,
oh commercial real estate is gonna die.
Other people say, no it
might be bigger than ever
because people need more space.
Where do you fall on that debate?
- All right, so this is
just a personal take,
but I think that it is a mistake
to write off personal interactions.
I think the workplace
might change in how we,
what we do in work, it will
become a lot more flexible.
But I think that this
need for human interaction
and the kind of ideas that
come through serendipity,
through bumping into someone in a hallway,
through the meeting that
takes place after the meeting.
You know, some of the best
projects we've ever done
that I've been involved with,
have come because the meeting is over
and a few of us stay
in the conference room
and all of a sudden someone
gets up to a whiteboard,
and says, you know actually,
what if we do it this way?
And you're like oh yeah,
that's exactly the way we should do it.
And off you go.
When you are doing these
kinds of teams or Zoom calls,
one half hour or half hour, half hour,
which is how a lot of us are working,
it's how I'm working right now,
you lose that spontaneity.
And I think there is a
real benefit for that,
and I think that we're really missing it.
So this morning, I got a chance
to go on a walking meeting
with someone who I haven't met before.
And we were planning on getting together,
it was the first time
I've done it since March.
We met in Prospect Park,
I'm based in New York, we met
in Prospect Park in Brooklyn,
and we walked side-by-side, our masks on.
And it was for 45 minutes.
We just talked about
questions that she'd had about
how to do something in her job.
And it was great.
And it was a free flowing conversation
in a way that I have not
experienced in a long time.
And I think that that is something that,
once we start getting that again,
it's gonna be hard to give it up.
So I'm not a believer in the full,
in that everyone goes virtual.
I just don't think it's sustainable.
- Yeah, maybe some type
of hybrid, more flexible.
I do want to double click
on the air travel thing
because those folks who've
watched this in the past,
know that myself and planes have not
had a good history together. (chuckling)
And, you know, even in my job,
obviously I have to travel a lot,
sometimes speak, sometimes,
you know, fundraise.
And to your point, I
actually find that I'm able
to have more efficient and
effective fundraising meetings
with potential donors right now
than before with all of that overhead.
And it creates, you know,
it's not good for the environment,
it's not good for people's
health, et cetera, et cetera.
Can we start a movement? (chuckling)
- To never travel again?
- Really, I mean, we should
travel to see our families,
and, you know, that type of thing,
go on vacation, see the world.
But, you know, this business travel,
let me go across country for a meeting
and then, you know, schlep back.
- Yeah, I'm with you.
(audio distorting)
- Let's start a LinkedIn movement.
- I'm with you, I'm part
of that LinkedIn movement.
There is no doubt.
I think that, going back to
your last question though,
I do think that it is easier
to have that kind of pledge
right now when we are all acting,
when we're all in this world.
Once there is a big enough
shift towards in-person,
everything goes in-person.
So I do think there's some
kind of network effect
that kind of happens
when you just don't want to feel left out.
Right now, you can't have FOMO today.
There is no room where it happens anymore.
It is a series of these small
rooms, virtually connected.
Once that room where it
happens, the idea comes back,
we're gonna all start getting back.
The pull to get back on the plane
is gonna start happening again.
But I'm with you.
I got to say the one surprising
upside of this is, you know
not to say that any of this is an upside,
this is a horrible situation
in the world we're living in
right now because of COVID,
but I'm spending way
more time with my family.
And it's really nice to not be
on a plane every other week.
So I'm not looking forward
to going back to that.
- No and, you know, we could
say that that's a nice to have,
from just like your own personal
contentment point of view.
But I believe having the
time with your family,
having a better family life,
connecting with your
kids, with your partner,
that's gonna make you better,
more effective at work.
And to your earlier
point, you can do more,
in that same amount of time
it takes to go across country
do one meeting and come back,
you could do 10 meetings,
which will be far less big.
Anyway, I'll get off.
We'll go offline and
think about how we can-
And you know, I have deep
sympathy for these industries
and hopefully there's
ways for them to pivot.
But you know, it has
never made sense to me,
and it seems to make
everyone I'm talking to,
they're like, yeah, my
life is so much better
now that I don't have
to travel all the time.
I was like, okay, let's
sign a pact right now.
(laughing)
- Right, let's never go back.
- It's bad for the
environment, it really is.
- I mean-
- Yeah, it is.
- It's horrible.
So a lot of questions that are coming in,
so one question I'll modify a little bit
from Smart Bear on YouTube,
"How do you think LinkedIn has
grown in the past five years?
And what do you think
it's going to look like
five years from now?"
- The number one way I would
say it's grown is in terms
of this explosion of
professional voice on LinkedIn.
This idea of sharing what you know
or sharing what you don't know,
and saying and being open and vulnerable
and saying I have
questions about how to do X
or I don't understand why Y is happening.
That was very different years ago.
It was hard to convince people
to write and share on LinkedIn
under their professional
identity, which we talked about.
It's no longer hard.
I think people still
have to think about it,
but it makes sense to them.
And I think that a younger generation
especially thinks of it as a given
that their voice needs to be heard,
that creating is part of who they are.
And I think that's a great thing.
This idea of democratizing
voice is something that
I think is one of the
best things to happen.
So before, when I was a
traditional journalist,
and when I was doing
a story for "Fortune,"
I would pick up the phone
and I might make 100 phone
calls for an article.
And then I would quote two people.
And I would have benefited
from those 98 other phone calls
and learning how an industry works
or what's going on behind the scenes.
But my readers never
got to see any of that.
They would see it all
filtered through my eyes,
but they never got the direct experience
of those quotes from these experts.
What we're seeing on LinkedIn
now is an outpouring of people
who are experts or want
to develop an expertise,
who are sharing what they know,
which helps all of us get smarter faster.
So that's probably been
the biggest change.
And I think it mirrors,
if you look at this thing
with Edelman, the PR firm,
does something called the Edelman
Trust Barometer every year
where they measure the entities
and institutions that people trust today,
it's a great read, you
should go check it out.
The number one most trusted
entity today is my CEO.
The people say my CEO, they're
the subject matter experts.
And there has been this drop in trust
in government and in the media.
But people believe in the people
who are signing their paychecks,
and they believe in people who
have some skin in the game.
And they want to hear more from them.
And what we're seeing is
that these executives,
these subject matter experts,
these people who were just coming up
are sharing this information on LinkedIn.
So that's the biggest.
In terms of what I think we'll
see in the next five years,
this kind of skills development
is, that we touched on,
I think it's gonna be a massive part
in what people use LinkedIn for.
If you come to LinkedIn,
you come to develop skills,
you use LinkedIn Learning
to get skilled up
in how to do Facebook ads
or how to learn R or
anything, Paddle or Python.
And you put on your profile
that you have developed that skill.
And for recruiters,
being able to see that,
you know, John Smith has a
skill in this area that we need,
is an instant validator in a way
that they haven't had before.
And so that kind of skill development
and putting skills on your profile,
showing off what you know,
and how you've learned it,
and then continuing to build off this,
and how you think,
which means like the postings
and articles that people are publishing,
that to me creates this explosion
of information on LinkedIn
that enables people to change
jobs or find better jobs,
or have the kind of
careers they want to have
where they can guide it themselves.
That's what I think is gonna happen.
- Yeah, that makes a ton of sense.
And related to that, this
question from Facebook,
Maria Akeem asks, "What advice can I give
my high schoolers graduating this year
who are unsure about what
major or field to look into,
given all the change that
we're talking about?"
- Great question.
All right, so I would say, number one,
is this has been true for
years, the most in demand skill
that we have heard from hiring managers
is the ability to communicate.
Communication skills
are the number one thing
that hiring managers are looking for.
And especially in a world like this,
where we are all behind our computers,
or writing on Google docs
or however else we're communicating,
this ability to be able to communicate
clearly and consistently is important.
So tell your high schooler, number one,
make sure that you are
learning how to write,
that you are very clear,
that you're taking English lessons,
that you are spending a lot of time
learning how to communicate.
Just be a great communicator.
That's number one.
Number two, if you want to
look at the jobs of the future,
we were just looking at,
sorry, I'm just pulling this up right now,
we did a look at what are some of the jobs
where we know that there
is outsized demand,
and we expect that kind of
outsized demand to continue.
So software developer,
sales representative,
project manager, IT
administrator, digital marketer,
IT support help desk,
basically anything, if
you can be anything around
how to make sure that people are-
We know that technology is underpinning
every single company today.
Every company is a tech company.
You want to have those
kinds of tech skills.
So I think that an engineering
degree always makes sense.
It might not be for everyone,
but if that is an area that
you have any interest in,
learning how to be an engineer
is a great thing to do.
Otherwise, sales is always really great.
So there's always gonna be a need
for someone for doing sales.
But if your teenager or high school grad
doesn't know what he or she wants to do,
just make sure that they are
learning how to communicate.
That is the key.
And the number two is make
sure that they are flexible,
that they learn how to ride the waves.
Because the kind of change
we see in industries today
is not gonna slow down.
And being able to adapt
to situations around you
is gonna be so important.
And being able to take
whatever you've learned,
and then adapt it, and go somewhere else,
you gotta know how to do that.
That's probably more
important than any major
that you can have today in college.
It is just understanding
how to adapt and how to stay flexible.
That's what I would say.
- If you were 22 years old,
maybe you have an engineering
degree, maybe you have
some other type of degree,
- I lost the sound.
- Oh, can you hear me now?
- I can't hear you.
- Oh well, we're at the home stretch.
- I think it was me.
- It might be me.
- Oh no.
- Let me see what the...
Whoa, I think it's me.
Can you hear me here?
- Nothing.
What's going on?
- Let me write you a note.
Well, I don't know, Filipe,
if you could tell Dan
to just, you know, any
parting thoughts for folks?
- So you can hear me,
I can't hear anything, unfortunately.
But this is part of
this staying adaptable.
So I'll tell you what I'm gonna do,
I'm gonna put my phone number
into this private chat that we have.
If you're watching this, I
don't think you can see this.
I hope not, otherwise everyone's
getting my phone number.
But if you wanna call,
maybe we can do it this way.
Or you can write out the
questions and I'll answer them.
- All right, let's see the chat.
- While we do this, can
I just say something?
Now I'm just gonna monologue.
I will say that we have on LinkedIn,
we keep a running list
of jobs that are hiring.
There are places that
are hiring right now.
It might feel like that
no one is actually hiring.
There are companies that are doing it.
Target, Amazon, UPS, FedEx, McDonald's,
Albertsons, Dollar General.
There are big companies
that are trying to hire,
that are continuing to
hire even in this pandemic.
And I do want to talk about a survey
that we did recently that
might be interesting,
which is we looked at people
who had lost their jobs.
And we talked to hiring
recruiters and hiring managers
about what they were looking for.
And a really interesting piece
of data came out of there,
two interesting pieces
of data come out of this.
One is that, people who
have lost their jobs
are incredibly ashamed and embarrassed
that they've lost their jobs.
46% said they have lied
about being unemployed.
And then when we talked
to hiring managers,
they said they don't care
whether someone is unemployed or not.
It makes no difference to
them in terms of hiring
and whether someone is currently employed.
So there's this incredible mismatch
in how people think about their work
and what companies are looking for.
That if you don't have a job,
it's okay not to have a job.
What hiring managers just want to know
is that you are continuing to stay busy,
that you're trying new things,
you're developing new skills,
that you're continuing to post and share
and explaining who you are.
But it's not something to hide from.
And I think that for a long time,
we have been led to believe that
you can only get a job if
you currently have a job,
or that you need to put on a fake front
and make it seem like
you're still working.
It's just not true.
The data says that this is not true.
That having a job is not
the most important thing
to getting your next job.
It is staying active, showing
that you're still involved,
that you are doing things
that are productive,
and that you are someone that a company
can get meaningful work out of,
right as soon as they hire you.
- And I'm assuming you can't hear me?
No.
- Nothing.
- Well what I will say
is, thank you (laughing)
for joining. (laughing)
- Thank you. (laughing)
- Yeah,
and we will do this again.
I'm trying to see how I
can communicate with you.
So I think we're all good. (chuckling)
So I don't know if all
of y'all can hear me,
my apologies for the technical
difficulties near the end.
But thanks everyone for joining.
Great conversation with Dan.
I hope we can bring him on again
'cause I had a ton of more questions,
although we did get pretty
close to running out of time.
But thanks everyone for joining.
Tomorrow, we're going to have Marley Dias,
author and founder of #1000BlackGirlBooks.
So we're looking forward to having her on,
and you know any questions you might have,
please bring those questions to us.
But with that, thanks for
joining today's live stream.
I will see you all soon.
(short snappy notes)